welcome back to our vax facts for kids
town hall i want to turn back to our
parents here on zoom again this is a mix
of vaccinated and unvaccinated
individuals here to listen to our
healthcare professionals about the
covid19 vaccine
you've been listening in has any of the
information changed your mind if it has
changed your mind because you could you
raise your hand
okay
now i do want to talk to brian almero
brian i think you're representative of
many parents you told me you're on the
fence could you sort of um tell me what
you thought of the information you heard
here today
well the information given by the two
professionals was very helpful uh but as
it stands i think i will still be in the
fence because this vaccine for children
under 12 is really so new
to where
uh it's kind of like the same thing for
me and my wife when we waited to get our
vaccine this is really finding out more
information about it
uh getting experiences from other
parents
uh because it's it's really a risk i
mean anything it's a risk but uh but for
my for our children i mean it's it's
much more important that make sure that
they're safe
so i mean my
stance that's still going to be in the
fence and really wait a few months maybe
it all depends on how much more
information i could gather and you know
facts and involvement so okay thank you
so much brian dr e what could you say to
wrap this up you know i would share that
again over 400 million doses have been
given in the united states and over 7
billion worldwide highly studied very
safe very effective against covid and
luckily against the delta variant as
well so you know we have something in
our arsenal to protect our community and
you know i'm encouraging people to
really consider it and talk to their
doctor if they have specific concerns
never forget to do that and joanne rue
piper of the southern nevada health
district i know you said there's many
resources for parents to do their own
research there definitely is i would
really encourage people to do their
research use credible resource
the cdc has good websites
children's hospital of philadelphia
healthy
healthychildren.org all really good
resources with videos and really can
give you a really good visual
thank you so much again thank you to our
parents for joining us we appreciate you
sharing your viewpoints thank you to our
health care professionals in the studio
we hope you had some of your questions
answered during this time as well we
have to wrap it up thank you so much
again for participating our vax facts
for kids town hall